on parle de ce sondage 71 % des Français
justuse que Jean-Luc Mélenchon est un
danger pour la République euh on non
mais cyil moi je faut faut juste
expliquer pourquoi il fait ça oui il est
pas fou il a lui-même donné la clé de du
mystère il a dit la dernière fois il m'a
manqué 400000 voies voilà je vais aller
chercher ces 400000 voies où il le dit
lui-même dans les quartiers donc il il
compte à la fois sur des nouveaux
électeurs et des anciens électeurs
égarés comme Gilles Verdez ce qui est ce
qui est particulièrement d'ailleurs
insultant pour les musulmans parce que
ça veut dire moi je trve c'est insultant
je trouve que c'est insultant pour les
Carti et ben oui parce qu'il pense que
tous les musulmans sont des islamistes
en fait c'est ça le calcul de de
Mélenchon donc non seulement il est
insultant envers la gauche il a trahi
toutes les valeurs de gauche et il est
insultant envers les gens dont il veut
obtenir les voix Mo la plart des
musulmans avec qui je parle et ils
veulent juste un truc ils veulent un
État palestinien un état israélien ils
veulent que les palestinens veent que
les il veulent que les Palestiniens
puissent vivre en paix dans un
territoire où ils peuvent vivre
correctement
et avec des moyens et ils veulent un
État d'Israël voilà souverain et qui
puisse aussi vivre
correctement Jean-Luc Mélenchon il se
trompe complètement sur les quartiers et
je vous le dis et dans les quartiers
j'ai encore eu encore je vous dis il y a
pas il y a pas de problème dans les
quartiers actuellement ce que je sais
pour l'instant il y a pas de problème
dans les quartiers donc jean-l Mélenchon
se plante et j'espère que sa stratégie
ne marchera pas il se plante d'autant
plus que cette semaine la BBC a diffusé
un documentaire réalisé à Gaza avec une
femme qui avait perdu une bonne partie
de sa famille et qui disait tout ça
c'est de la faute des chiens du Hamas
c'est une phrase qui dont vous entendrez
parler elle a dit elle a elle a qualifié
les le Hamas de chien du Hamas c'est
quoi la nouvelle idée de de la France
insoumise non je voulais tout à l'heure
dire que la dernière idée de la France
insoumise c'est à propos de la de la
presse et de la la polémique sur
Guillaume mauris c'est de créer un
conseil de surveillance de la presse
c'est-à-dire que moi ça me rappelle tout
simplement les talibans au début début
2000 lorsqu'ils avaient créé le
ministère de la
la ver de la justice et de la vertu et
qui disait à qui voulait bien entendre
ce qu'il fallait dire ou ne pas dire
c'est exactement la même chose on est en
train de prendre une direction qui est
dramatiquefi sa dernière proposition
c'est création d'un conseil de
surveillance de ce qui on pourra dire
dans la presse il évidment ça qu'une
proposition pour le moment mais on voit
bien la direction qu' sont en train de
prendre d'un mot ce qui me choquei c'est
qu' a les bon et les mauvais
journalistes retrouver les propos que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a prononcé à
l'encontre de Karine bcard adjoint du
chef de service politique de France
interre qui l'a invité refuse d'aller à
son émission mais regardez les mots
qu'il utilise pour qualifier une
journaliste du service public alors il y
a les bons il y a les bons humoristes il
y a les mauvaises humoristes il y a les
bons journalistes et les mauvaises
journalistes je suis désolé dans notre
pays il y a des journalistes et on
respecte les journalistes on peut tre en
désaccord avec les journalistes mais il
y a pas d'un côté les bons parce que ils
disent que Jean-Luc Mélenchon est
formidable et que LFI c'est le parti
politique le meilleur non on respecte
les journalistes dans une démocratie
ouais alors euh qui oui qu'est-ce qui se
passe non mais quand éc dit que c'est
honteux parce qu'il va chercher dans les
quartiers les 400000 voix qui lui
manquent il fait de la politique
Mélenchon il fait de la politique
désolé est-ce que est-ce qu' est-ce
qu'on fait de la politique dans un
moment comme celui-là c'est ce
que est-ce que tu acceptes qu'on fasse
de la politique dans un moment comme
celui-l non mais il fait de la politique
après moi je suis pas le porte-parole de
Jean-Luc manchon
il vot musul mais non mais quand vous
dites
islamiste musulmans Islamist ça c'est de
la phraséologie pour diaboliser Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ce que vous allez obtenir de
mon point de vue c'est que les gens il
avait fait 68 % du vote musulman la
prochaine fois ce sera 95 % du vote
musulman parce que les musulmans mais
oui mais les musulmans ne vont plus se
reconnaître qu'en lui c'est ça Gill toi
tu vas voter pour Jean-Luc si je voulais
non mais moi je me dérroe pas hein s'il
est le candidat de l'Union de la gauche
il sera arrête arrête de tourner autour
du PO bah je tourne pas autour du pot je
vous répond franchement c'est pas sûr
qu'il y a une union de la gauche il aura
peut-êre différente tu adhère à quoi de
son programme alors vu qu'il n'ose pas
nommer les choses quand elles sont
effroyabl mais moi je vote à gauche donc
je vote en citoyen disciplin à gauche
c'est l'extrême gauche c'est pas la même
chose s'il est le candidat je peux pas
le dire plus clairement s'il est le
candidat de l'Union de la gauche V pour
luici que tu es islamiste pardon le
candidat des Islamist pas le candidat
mais AR qu on veut pas qualifier le
Hamas de mouvementes de la politique là
c'est pas bien ce que vous faites ce qui
est incroyable c'est que moi g j'étais
convaincu que tu étais de gauche gauche
humaniste c'est quoi la gauche humaniste
c'est la gauche à l'ancien la gauche
humaniste et ce la gauche sociale plus
commente n'iste
plus donc tu es d'accord avec moi la
gauche n'existe
plus la gauche de Mélenchon c'est de
l'opportunisme pour moi c'est de la
récupération politique tu dis que c'est
de la politique c'est de la récupération
ce qu'il est en train de faire il a
complètement glisser on le voit
exactement le mec se dit tiens où est-ce
que je vais a raison où est-ce que je
vais aller récupérer les voix qui me
manque il prend les musulmans pour des
cons exactement ce qu'il fait en ce
moment et c'est la récupération
politique et c'est extrêmement dangereux
moi c'est mon avis guaume tu es d'accord
avec le sondage sû qu' divise la France
oui je suis d'accord avec le sondage
mais je pense qu'il fait il fait une
récupération et une instrumentalisation
de ce conflit qui est dégueulasse qui
vise à monter les gens les uns contre
les autres qui fait plein de
sous-entendus qui encore une fois sont
dégueulasses qui sont ABS qui
sous-entend que tous les musulmans
seraient antisémites qui qui qui voilà
donc je je pense qu'il est extrêmement
dangereux je pense que son calcul est
mauvais et je pense aussi qu'il y a
plein de gens qui ont voté Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui aujourd'hui sont très
déçus parce qu'il découvrent son vrai
visage et d'ailleurs on voit bien que
dans son propre parti les gens se
désolidarisent et depuis quelques mois
maintenant c'est la catastrophe à cause
de lui donc j'ai une question pour G
est-ce que tu penses que 29 % des
Français pensent qu'effectivement le
Hamas n'est pas une organisation
terroriste non mais moi je suis en
désaccord avec ce qu'il a dit pourant
tuisamment grave
et er tua posé une question très très
intéressant tout à l'heure qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait que Fass Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pour que tu ne votes pas pour
lui h là il a fait une erreur historique
il faudrait pas qu'il en fasse d'autres
comme ça une erreur historique ça vous
suffit pas pour changer votre vote
parfait parfait
jeis ça ne suffit pas pour faire changer
ma voix la police lace sur la poli sur
la police ce qui dit sur la police et la
façon dont il a parlé au policiers sur
mon plateau ça suffit pas je ne suis pas
d'accord avec lui sur la police je ne
suis pas d'accord avec lu je ne suis pas
d'accord avec lui mais cy moi mais mais
là vous m'engueulez vous me tombez
dessus pas d'accord avec moi je vote
mais moi je vote à gauche moi je vote à
gauche donc laissez-moi non mais mais là
mais je su la loi parce que je vote à
gauche P
à vous tapez t sur il y a des gens qui
votent à droite avec des hommes
politiques on fait des dingueries à
droite des dingueries vous regardez sur
internet a des mecs on été condamné et
les gens ont pas changé de vote ils ont
continué à voter à droite des mecs ont é
en prison sont sortis de prison des gens
onoté pour
vous êes deberin de
dire%
mten
oui euh moi je suis très mal à l'aise
avec ce sondage et je suis très mal à
l'aise sur le fait de donner un oui ou
un non pourquoi parce que pour moi
Jean-Luc Mélenchon effectivement a fait
une très très grave erreur de ne pas
dire que c'est des terroristes en
revanche ce qu'il a fait et c'était le
précurseur c'est de dire au tout début
oui ce qui s'est passé en Israël c'est
horrible il y avait un émoi mondial et
tout ça mais qu'est-ce qu'il en a été à
la base de la Palestine donc c'est quoi
c'est qui de l'œuf ou de la poule si
c'est ça et c'est pour ça que grâce à
lui il y a eu des marches par comprend
pas ce que tu dis en fait non j'ai pas
compris rapport début de la Palestine
laiss-moi laisse-moi mais parce que ce
qui a été fait en Palestine avant on n
parlait pas oui mais ça n'a rien à voir
avec un acte terroriste attent un
attentat
s il y avait un foisonnement non mais
s'il vous plaît en fait il y avait un
foisonnement de manifestation pour
l'Israël lui a pu mettre en place des
manifestation pour la Palestine et c'est
grâce à ça il a des gens d'un côté
attends c'est grâce à ça qu'en
conclusion on est tous d'accord pour
dire
aujour'hui certainement pas
moi et c'est grâce à des gens
excuse-moic je par j'ai encore parlé
depuisbutionci c'est parce que il y a
des gens comme ça d'un côté il y a des
gens de l'autre que aujourd'hui en
conclusion peut dire on veut juste des
marches pour la pai pas March pour la p
a pu servir à
ça il veut pas la p en
fa fait oui je comprend je comprends pas
ton ton point de vue en fait tu justif
une action terroriste sous prétexte que
ça se passait mal avant en fait c'est ça
l'idée non mais pas du tout moi j'essaie
juste de comprendre ce qu'il voulait
dire je t' dit je t'ai dit que le Hamas
effectivement il a fait une erreur de
dire que c'est pas terroriste en
revanche eu ce qu'il disait il disit
attendez il se passe ça est-ce qu'on
peut pas aller dans
l'antériorité fait attention parce que
quand il y a des crimes d'une barbarie
sans nom quand on voit ce que j'ai vu je
suis allé au camp de Choura je revois
une la secouriste qui me dit regardez on
a vu un ama de chair je pensais que
c'était une femme brûlée il font un IRM
le lendemain elle apprend que c'est une
femme et son bébé brûle et vif vous
pouvez pas dire Jean-Luc Mélenchon a la
vertu de nous ramener dans le temps long
de l'histoire il y a quelque chose qu'
l' à dépassé le conflit
israelllo-palestinien ce n'est plus vous
faites vraiment un raccourci sur ce que
je vous dis faites attention non je dis
faites attention
attention attention non mais attendez
est-ce que quelqu'un ne comprend pas
français là en fait
on comprend très bien moi je pense que
tu es en train de commettre une erreur
très importante c'est que tu tombes dans
le piège idéologique de
Mélenchon qui tombe dans le panneau de
Mathilde ah du tout non mais je je dis
que je dis ça Cyr parce que justement
Mélenchon veut tout faire pour nous
obliger à être soit d'un côté soit de
l'autre et ça n'est pas le sujet on te
parle
d'humanité tout le monde sait
excuse-moic tout le monde sait que je ne
suis pas une pro Mélenchon et je vais
encore une fois repréciser mon il a fait
une grave erreur de dire que ce n'est
pas terroriste en revanche laisso
par s pass avant VI en revanche c'est le
premier qui a dit les gars juste on est
sur les Mo est-ce qu'on peut dire aussi
que la Palestine a le droit de faire ses
manifestations et tout ça et moi j'ai
dit bien sûr Israël a droit de faire ses
manifestations mais la Palestine aussi
je crois que tu étais d'accord avec moi
et maintenant si au lieu de choisir son
camp de foot on peut
dire premier c'est un opportuniste il il
contradcteuradcteur pardonnez-moi il y a
une autre faille dans votre raisonnement
c'est ce que vous appelez les
manifestations pour la paix il y a un
mélange de gens qui sont sincèrement
attachés à la cause palestinienne
mélanger à des gens qui portent des
autocollants à la gloire des types qui
ont découpé des bébés et mélanger à des
gens qui vous disent les massacres en
Israël n'ont pas existé donc c'est
mélangé dans ces manifestations avec des
négationistes avec des négationistes en
direct
que vous appelez des manifestations pour
la toutes les manifestations des Feurs
de
merde majorité des gens qui vont
manifester c'est parce que ils sont
choqués par le nombre impressionnant de
gens qui meurent en Palestine en ce
moment et de
laisser la majorité
mer
parce que non j'ai commencé par les
autres j'ai commencé par les autr j'ai
commencé par les
autres commc manif moi je trouve ça très
bien a une manifestation là autorisée
pour le moment organisé ou monter par
LFI ce weekend pour
soutenir monter par LFI c'est une
pression très juste oui mais je viens de
le dire montage non mais non mais
attendez laissez-moi finir une phrase je
trouve ça très bien que non mais je
trouve ça très bien que les gens bah non
mais j'ai le droit de par aller non mais
je vais pas dans les manies je vais pas
dans les man compqué voilà je trouve ça
très bien que les gens qui sont pro
Palestiniens manifestent en France ça a
été trop inter on l'a tous dit ici on
l'a tous dit ici on
l' de la France insoumise Boyard vient
de dire notre objectif c'est la panique
dans la rue c'est son tweet qui vient de
sortir sortez mais attendez vous
êtesrend je dis les manifestations et je
dis
manifestation je parle des manif et je
c une manifestation organisée par la
France les gens qui vont manifester
c'est parce qu'ils ont envie ont envie
que les gens arrêtent de crever sous les
bombes moi jeis vous dire les gens qui
organisent les manifestations ils avent
pas besoin de la France insoumise mais
oui mais c'est très
bien je vis qu'on voie la vidéo d'éic n
hier soir hier sur ces news
regardez mon métier c'est de commenter
mais là je peux pas non c'est trop dur
bon c'est trop de ça fait depuis le 7
octobre effectivement qu'on est tous
sous cette charge émotionnelle et
imaginez qu'on puisse en arriver à
mettre un bébé vivant dans un fou pour
je comprends votre émotion
éic alors ça c'était hier chez notre ami
Laurence Ferrari vous avez été submergé
par l'émotion éic nollo bah ce qui est
étonnant c'est pas que je cède à
l'émotion et que je pleure c'est ce qui
est étonnant c'est que tout le monde ne
pleure pas je trouve en France ou quand
on quand on entend le récit de ces
abominations je crois que c'est le
moment de pleurer ou en tout cas que
chacun réagisse selon sa propre
sensibilité mais c'est certainement pas
le le moment des petit calcul politique
à la Mélenchon voilà France insoumise
voilà ce que je dis quand on a le cœur
au bon endroit le cerveau au bon endroit
on est déjà solidaire des victimes et
quand on parle de victimes il il y a pas
eu d'acte aussi atroce depuis le nazisme
en réalité ces gens-là sont des nazis et
sur ces agissements là vous avez des
gens qui disent est-ce que ce sont
vraiment des terroristes un bébé vivant
dans un four et ventrer une femme
enceinte est-ce que c'est vraiment
terroriste juste monsieur le député il
il y a beaucoup de gens aussi j'ai vu
sur les réseaux qui disent que c'est une
c'est une fausse information est-ce que
tu une vraie information ou pas mais la
barbarie c'est une vraie information
j'ai vu les camionons frigorifiques
s'ouvrir devant
moi je les ai vu j'ai entendu cette dame
me dire de manière totalement
sincère il y a un enfant et une mère qui
ont été brûlé vif ensemble j'ai vu
l'odeur insoutenable ce qui est
révoltant dans ce que fait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est que il aurait dû dire
que c'était des crimes contre l'humanité
enfin bon sens c'est quand même pas
compliqué de dire que c'est des crimes
d'une barbarie sans nom et une fois
qu'il a dit ça madame vous avez raison
il aurait pu dire on parle d'histoire on
réfléchit on parle de paix mais il
aurait dû commencer par dire c'est des
crimes d'une barbarie sans nom on a tué
30 français tout le monde s'en fout il y
a neu aotages il y a nef
aotages non mais non non mais il y a ne
Fages il y a ne photages juste dire une
chose j'ai grandi moi avec à la
télévision les bandeaux de George
malbruno et d'ERV gekier ils sont où les
bandeaux dans notre pays pour demander
la libération des neuf otages vous
parliz de manifestation je terminerai là
moi je suis pour des manifestations pour
la paix est-ce qu'il y a un drapeau
israélien est-ce qu'il parle des otages
il y a pas eu une mention dans les
manifestations sur la libération des
nototages il y a neu français
aujourd'hui qui sont des compatriotes il
y a pas de mention c'est pas des
rassemblements pour la paix des
rassemblements pour la paix on parle des
otages on parle des français morts il y
a des drapeaux israéliens et
palestiniens ça c'est magif P jeis vous
montrer je vais vous montrer une vidéo
c'est la vidéo qui a fait le plus parler
aujourd'hui c'est une publication en
ligne évoquant le le meurtre d'un bébé
qui aurait été brûlé dans un four et
aujourd'hui cette vidéo fait énormément
parler c'est une influenceuse enfin une
influenceuse une une abrutie plutôt qui
a traité ce sujet avec une ironie
insoutenable je sais pas si vous avez vu
cette
vidéo regardez non mais c'est une folle
mais c'est une folle mais ça circule sur
les réseaux et ça a été énormément vu
donc les chériis quand on parle des
réseaux un moment un moment il faut
vraiment que les mecs réveill comm la
vidéo des jeunes les mecs se réveillent
sur les réseaux parce que ça devient
n'importe quoi je vous dis et ça ça a
énormément circulé avant d'être enlevé
donc regardez cette vidéo abusé moi il y
a une chose qui me qui me ture le pine
je je je je vais je vais je vais vous
donner le fond de ma pensée sans filtre
à chaque fois que je tombe sur
l'histoire du bébé qui a été mis dans le
four je me pose la question de siis en
mis du sel du poivre s'ils ont mis du
thin ils l'ont fait revenir à quoi et et
ça a été quoi
l'accompagnement vous posez pas la
question vous je sais pas accompagnement
avec ce gigot de bébé n'était qu'autre
qu'une assiette de frites avec une sauce
ketchup et
mayonnaise et on l'a mariné avec du sel
du thint et avec une sauce
barbe pas mal moi je trouve que c'est un
un menu plutôt pas mal c'est grave c'est
là où mélange ça ça ça ça c'est une
vidéo qui a circulé ça est-ce que vous
vous rendez compte moi je pense pas que
ce soit marginal moi je pense qu'il y a
un antisémitisme très très important
dans notre pays not P on s'en rend comp
autreuse aussi qui marchait sur le
drapeau israélien je sais pas si vous
l'avez vu une vidéo pareil où elle
décrit son look et cetera et où elle dit
ah j'ai pas oublié Israël et elle a sous
la chaussure sous sa semelle le drapeau
israélien ça être interdit du terrorisme
mais là là c'est insoutenable c'est là
où les hommes c'est là où les hommes
politiques et les médias ont un ont un
devoir c'est que ils sont en train
d'infuser ils sont en train d'infuser de
libérer une parole et comme par hasard
on a toute une série comme ça de débiles
mentaux qui bascule dans le
négationnisme ou dans l'antisémitisme et
c'est ça le problème ce dont on parle
avec Guillaum Moris tu me parles de tu
me parles de je suis char non tu peux
pas être Charlie lorsqu'il s'agit de
basculer dans quelque chose qui est
interdit ça tombe sous le coup de la loi
c'est du racisme pur et dur on ne peut
pas l'excuser parce que c'est un
humoriste ou un mec intelligent je m'en
fous tout ce qui se passe en ce moment
c'est que la France insoumise est en
train de libérer tout un tas de dingu il
désinh la parole il désinhible la parole
vous avez tout à fait raison et après on
se retrouve avec ces gens-là qui
attisent la haine qui creusent la
société qui nous fracture c'est
terrible c'est contre et c'est contre un
des trois principe de la République la
fraternité la fraternité ils sont en
contravention fait la vidé je vous
remercie monsieurs les députés je vous
remercie éc nollo d'avoir été avec nous